flags at government buildings once again
fly at half star from the president's
orders
just as they did a week ago following a
mass shooting in atlanta
among the 10 killed in boulder colorado
was a 51 year old police officer
eric talley his fellow officers and
citizens
paid tribute as his body was taken to
the morgue
gun violence is a pandemic within a
pandemic
we know about 50 million guns were sold
in the last year
many of them to people who live in
states that don't require a background
check or training or permitting
and the president has called for a
bipartisan push to institute
stronger gun controls we can ban assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines in
this country
once again i got that done when i was a
senator
it passed it was law for the longest
time
and it brought down these mass killings
we should do it again
two bulls making it more difficult to
buy a gun
have been passed in the house of
representatives in recent weeks
but they are likely to face strong
opposition when brought to the senate
for years democrats have pushed for
action to stop this killing with common
sense reform
that will save lives for years we've
been blocked by republican leaders
and their special interests now we can
act
and we will the divisions remained on
sharp display in the senate judiciary
committee session on gun control
scheduled before the shootings in recent
days
thoughts and prayers are not enough
and yet thoughts and prayers is all we
have heard from my colleagues on
the other side thoughts and prayers must
lead to action i agree
it is time for us to do something and
every time there's a shooting
we play this ridiculous theater
where this committee gets together and
proposes a bunch of
laws that would do nothing to stop these
murders
the legislation that's been passed in
the house falls far
short of the president's call for a ban
on automatic weapons
and high-capacity magazines it proposes
extending the background check period
from 3 to 10 days yet given the visceral
republican opposition to any form of gun
control
even this moderate measure is unlikely
to get the 60 votes needed in the senate
to become law mike al jazeera
washington